the jurogan experience i forgot you guys
are competitive let me tell you
oh yeah jamie's been whacking that ball
son
he's got a spooky drive but what jamie
knows is it said it's not exactly a test
of strength i mean he can hit the ball
very hard and very far does that make
you jealous
no it should no because we're not
talking jealous
and i don't even play golf a big part of
the game joe is where you hit the ball
yeah yeah you can get that eventually
exactly right like if somebody kicked
really hard but they didn't kick you
yeah but no no no no no no no
no no this smile just went off what he's
saying
what he's saying is how i approached
martial arts i learned how to kick hard
first and then i learn how to kick
people
kick hard first then you figure out
where to kick them well you kick hard
first and kick fast and then it's about
closing distance and fainting
no no it's less complicated
kicking someone's way more complicated
the ball doesn't move shut the [ __ ] up
don't ever say that i mean there's not a
chance in hell that it's easier to hit a
golf ball that it's not easier to hit a
golf ball than just kick somebody not a
chance in [ __ ] hell you know how
smart golfers are and how dumb fighters
are
you know you don't know what you're
talking about what i'm saying is
it's super difficult to kick someone
it's super easy to hit a golf ball
whether you hit a golf ball perfectly
that's a different story whether you hit
it i mean it's easy to hit again it's
right there it's not moving anywhere
it's right there neither is the bag that
you're kicking we're talking about a
person kicking a person
that's what we're talking about that's
what you're you're saying like fighters
are dumb like to be able to close the
distance fighters are dumb i'm just
saying that no they're dumb compared to
golfers he said dumb fighters
you don't think the style bender is
smarter than john daly you're out of
your [ __ ] mind
i mean you're out of your [ __ ] mind
they're both no that's a tough one i bet
he could do uh survive a night partying
better than style bender well of course
robin is healthy
i mean that's not a dis to style blender
i'm just saying john daly's all there
he's got a lot of great stories very
funny guys very present no brain zero
brain damage a lot of liver damage no
hangovers
doesn't feel all hangovers
ever ever how is it possible that's what
he said i was gonna show you the video
earlier i don't that's what he's got
he's a professional isn't it amazing
that avoids sugar you can be an a
full-on alcoholic
and excel at golf doesn't that throw
your [ __ ] idea of intelligence and
strategy and all that away like you
don't even have to have control of your
body you can be an alcoholic okay the
greatest fighter of all time is jon
jones i rest my case yeah but jon jones
never showed up high
you don't think
you're so funny right now this is like
our pro wrestling talks when you take a
stand on something you will say the
crazy nick diaz has shown up and fought
high when he fought gomi he was high uh
they suspended him for a long time he
got he tested positive like through the
roof of uh his marijuana levels like
when he fought gome he was high he got
gomi in a go-go plata which is a crazy
move to pull off in mma super [ __ ]
rare
if you watch how he sets it up he he
gets hit by gomi i think gome even
fractured his cheek he goes into the
guard gomi was a [ __ ] powerful
puncher because gomi would throw punches
the way a fastball like a pitcher would
throw a fastball because he was a
baseball player so gomi had like that
whip from throwing basketball
baseball rather did i say basketball i
said baseball right like you would throw
a fastball and he would apply that whip
to punching and he cracked nick and had
this big [ __ ] cut on his cheeks
cheeks well up and they went to the
ground and nick wrapped him up in a gogo
plata and uh
put his arm his his arm trapped in one
leg shin underneath the neck and then
gable grips behind the neck and pulls
down on his death
it's a crazy move to get somebody in the
first place even crazier when you're
high as [ __ ] and he was fighting high
yeah wasn't that sort of the same thing
jon jones to cormier i beat you after a
weekend of cocaine the doublest
the double champ well that was the week
before he said a weekend of cocaine he
didn't beat him after he didn't like do
cocaine that
week he did it the week before the fight
and on top of that he wasn't fighting on
coke nick diaz was fighting high
john parties a lot yeah but
if you look at john without a shirt off
and you'll get john daly without a shirt
off you're not making any confusion i
mean yes if we're having a beauty
pageant no no no no no no no no no no no
no no no if you want to decide hey one
of these guys is an athlete
and one of these guys plays a game drunk
which one do you think it is
yeah you got me there
i mean i don't think that he's not
awesome at golf he's a [ __ ] amazing
golf player there's no doubt about it
i've watched videos of john daly play
he's incredible i think it's just
amazing that a guy could be like known
for being addicted to essentially a drug
and just on it all the time and plays on
it smokes cigarettes and drinks
drinks diet coke like 16 diet cokes a
day yeah